hi there steve here again day 73 i think
or 74 i can't
remember i should check it before i
start my video
um didn't do much today mostly i
listened uh
and watched in russian mostly listened
because the whole situation in the
ukraine is so fascinating all the
politicians there they're all well i'll
get back to that later but
um did a bit of korean
and uh you know i tried to go back to my
whole you know consolidating thing but i
just have trouble listening to and
reading content that has no meaning
so i'm back to my podcast
and i'm just resigned to the fact that
uh it's gonna take a long time and if if
i think of it
you know russian i i listened to and i
read for five years uh czech was a year
and a half
um
what romanian was three months but i
wasn't you know i didn't get that far
but it would have been faster
um
i think with the ukrainian i read
through the book there and
i can't learn words in this in the
boring content that's there if i were a
total beginner to slavic languages and
i'd spend more time with it now i'm
really looking for words i got a sense
of how the verbs uh
you know conjugate and so forth so i'm
going back to my interesting content
but i think if i were to spend and you
know as much as i i do that i know in
listening to uh ukrainian that to get to
where i can really understand it it
would still be months and months maybe
four or five six months there is no
shortcut maybe that's the message there
is no shortcut
um and korean is gonna take me another
at least six months of what i'm doing
now to get to uh
you know what i call an educated
person's level
in korean there are no shortcuts i can
try to get to so that i can converse on
topic a but that's not really meaningful
in terms of my goals so i'm just
resigned to the fact that it's going to
take me that long
the biggest problem because there are no
shortcuts the biggest problem in
language learning is time
now unless of course you have a very
limited um goal
just be able to say a few things and and
fine but to really understand what
people are saying to be able to enjoy
the culture
it takes time
um now uh now that i'm in the ukrainian
people saying i should also learn polish
and of course i should so now i'm
thinking that my wife and i we should be
we should go travel in poland and
ukraine
and i guess polish based on russian and
czech now and a little bit you not
really but if i were to do some
ukrainian and then polish i mean i think
in a year i could have those to where
you know i could operate
however
this other couple and my wife and i are
planning to go to vietnam
next spring and i wanted to get going on
vietnamese and see if we could encourage
people to create content for link in
vietnamese
so
you know it's it's just there isn't
enough time i i don't understand people
say gee you know i was with this fellow
the other day who's been a very
successful businessman and he still goes
to his company he's 70 years old and he
sold his company and he said yeah i
don't know what i'm going to do when i
retire
like there isn't enough time in the day
i can't read the books that i want to
read in english on history and stuff
like that that i buy i've got my
sporting activities my family i want to
travel with my wife and i want to learn
all these languages there's not enough
time how can you worry about what you're
going to do when you retire i don't
understand
but you see this sort of path here i for
the longest time of course i learned
chinese right and then japanese so that
was and i call that the cynic
s-i-n-i-c even though japanese is a
different language system from chinese
it's not a
sino-tibetan language however it's part
of the chinese cultural world
so within that chinese cultural world
you've got chinese japanese korean and
vietnamese
and i gather that vietnamese just like
japanese and korean shares a lot of
vocabulary with chinese although
pronounced a little differently
so that's my
chinese world call it cynic sinic world
and for the longest time i was very much
into my romance languages world
and if you take spanish and portuguese
and italian and french of course and
i've also toyed with the idea of
learning
uh catalan but i can read catalan it's
that close and similar with gallego i
can read it
so there you've got the romance world
which is actually after all 750 million
people that's quite large the cynic
world is larger it's 100 1.5 billion
people or whatever the number is
um
and then of course i did my german and
swedish so call that the germanic world
which is not as large
and now i've been in the slavic world
with my
check and i went to slovakia and
discovered that i could understand some
and i could read the signs so there and
of course my russian which started it
all and which is the biggest chunk of
the slavic world
there are apparently 250 million russian
speakers
probably a hundred and uh
you know there's 140 in russia i don't
know what the population of belarus is 5
or 10 million
and then in ukraine native speakers of
russians probably half the population so
that's another 20 million so there's
probably 170 million native speakers but
then if you include all speakers of
russian it's probably like 250 million
and then you throw in polish and then
the native ukrainian speakers and the
people who speak the south slavic
languages
uh i don't know what it all adds up to
but um that's got to throw
another
100 million people
on there so there's 350 million slavic
language speakers
and of course with each of these
languages you get interested in the
history the culture you want to travel
there and stuff like that so there's
lots to do there's lots to do i want to
stay with my korean i want to do the
vietnamese i want to go back to chinese
i still love my french my spanish my
japanese i mean there's just no shortage
of stuff to do but i gotta block all of
that out and somehow go back to the
korean you know what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna phone my friend mr che mr toy at
our golf club who speaks in some strange
regional pronunciation but still maybe
suggest that we have lunch a couple of
times a week
maybe i'll play golf with them and if he
humors me and speaks to me in korean we
will see okay now i'm gonna go watch the
canucks i've got the tame the game
recorded downstairs finished dinner in
the dishes and talk to you later bye